MURDERS OVERALL.
WHAT LESSON SHOULD WE DRAW FROM
THIS?
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON IS A
HISTORIAN AND SENIOR OF THE
HOOVER INSTITUTION.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT CONCLUSIONS DO DRAW?
>> WELL, I THINK USUALLY IN
NORMAL TIMES, TUCKER, THAT WE
DON'T DO INSANE THINGS LIKE LET
PEOPLE OUT WITH NO BAIL OR DO
NOT PROSECUTE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ARRESTED OR LET FELONS OUT OF
PRISON, BUT THESE ARE CONFINED
TO THE CAMPUS, CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, CRITICAL PENAL THEORY, I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS COVID OR
THE LOCKDOWN OR GEORGE FLOYD OR
THE 120 DAYS OF RIOTING IN
SUMMER OF 2020, OR THE STRANGE
102 MAIL-IN BALLOTS DEFINING THE
LEFT-WING AGENDA, BUT THESE
ACADEMIC THEORIES GOT MAINSTREAM
INTO ACTUAL POLICIES OF
DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND LETTING
CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL, AND WE
LOST DETERRENCE, SO THE C